all right this week's voicemail we've
heard from this gentleman before I don't
know what to call this gentleman but
he's someone who calls in with is it
fair to say like religious advice yeah I
don't know how to even vice the word
it's not really advice it's just sort of
preaches it's it's preaching of some
kind yeah anyway to 192 david p is our
voicemail number and here is a bit of i
guess we can call it wisdom for us on
this rainy at least here in
massachusetts monday a very dark and
gloomy monday here's a bit of a I don't
know what to call it let's just listen
to it there's a foul on God's kingdom
God's kingdom is a government that
Jehovah set up in heaven Jesus Christ is
ruling as its King and the future
Jehovah will use the kingdom to remove
all wickedness God's kingdom will rule
over the earth
we've not edited the voicemail that's if
you're saying oh that might make sense
if we heard the full context that's the
full context like yeah there's just
nothing else I don't know does this
relate to anything like a story we've
covered recently I heard to me that it
might but it's so cryptic that I
couldn't even begin to figure out what
it relates to yeah I need an explainer I
think just the text alone from the Bible
isn't gonna do it for me yeah if
somebody can leave a voicemail
explaining that voicemail that might be
useful to us and then we could maybe
follow up and figure out what that was
all about we've got a great bonus show
today we will talk about States bailing
out
Lady Liberty and grand the grand I guess
it's called Grand Canyon National Park
is that the foaming so yeah for what we
know of as the Grand Canyon during the
government shutdown we will talk about
Amazon's surveillance powered no
checkout convenience store and we will
also talk about this week's flu this
week's this year's flu rather this
year's flu is a bad one it's a bad one
and it's getting worse and now we are
starving the CDC of funding of course
because obviously we all know why and
how is that going to affect treating the
flu and by the way I do want to make a
little bit of a comment on the
show about the flu vaccine conspiracy
theorist if you will allow me to go in
that direction they're gonna plan for
that I think we will I think we will get
access to the bonus show one of two ways
become a member at david pakman.com
slash membership you will get instant
access become a patron at at least the
$5 a month level at patreon.com slash
david pakman show you'll get instant
access to the full archive of
world-famous bonus shows we will speak
to you then